lawmakers are continuing to debate if
they should help finance a stadium right
here in Las Vegas for the A's of course
8 News Now
Ripple joining us to explain what this
bill actually looks like and how day two
of the special session is going so far
Brian and Denise the senate committee
heard public testimony for against an
even neutral on a bill for more than two
hours last night there has been no
action taken on the bill as of right now
and it doesn't look like there will be
until Monday the assembly and the Senate
have both adjourned until Monday the
Senate was originally set to meet at 11
30 this morning as for what lawmakers
have been saying comments in opposition
to the a Stadium plan objected to using
State money to subsidize the stadium
when that money could be used for other
needs while comments and support say it
will bring Economic Opportunity and draw
more possible events to the area to
utilize the stadium in the off season
there's even discussion about adding
additional legislation to the bill like
making the stadium pay the live
entertainment tax
there's been a legislative session that
just ended and there's a lot of
legislation there that also didn't make
it all the way through that finish line
and attaching it to this conversation is
very prudent I think can allow for this
conversation to move further
overall the bill seeks to provide a
combination of bonds and tax incentives
that would cap out at 380 million
dollars for the 30 000 seat baseball
stadium at the site of the Tropicana
Hotel in addition to funding to help
with homelessness here in Clark County
it also requires 15 percent of the
stadium be work completed by the use of
local and small businesses there hasn't
been a whole lot of progress on day two
of this special session which leaves the
question of the A's coming to Las Vegas
still up in the air we'll continue to
follow the progress of this session and
keep you updated